[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHELLE XU: This
is session CMP202,
and we'll be talking about
high performance computing HPC
partner ecosystem
at Google Cloud.
You can submit your questions
and comments on Dory.
And if you're not familiar with
Dory yet, you have a neighbor.
Turn to your left or
turn to your right.
We're sure, you know,
there are some Dory experts
in the audience.
And also, did you know that you
can also thumb up or thumb down
some Dory comments, or
anybody else's Dory comments,
and so the most popular Dory
comments will be pushed up
to the top of the
queue, and that
will really get our attention.
So let's get it started.
My name is Michelle Xu.
I'm with Google Cloud's global
technology partnership team.
My job is to make sure that
Google Cloud and our partners
work together, and that
we deliver solutions
so the end users can adopt
Cloud easily, quickly,
and cost effectively.
And some of our partners
are here today with me.
Spoiler alert, we have
a couple of demos.
So we'll begin with
a personal story.
I was an engineer, I
was a graduate student.
I studied optics,
integrated circuits,
optical communication, and
then, later, atomic physics.
So scientific computation
is, very much, near and dear
to my heart.
And thinking back
more than a decade ago
when I was running
simulations, I only really
had a couple of choices.
Either I run a very rudimentary
simulation compressed
on my own desktop,
or I can submit
the 3D jobs, the very
complex, the real problems,
into a data center, and then had
to wait in a queue for a week.
Time has changed.
All of these machines are
available at our fingertips.
And why Google Cloud?
Google's data
center and our cloud
has supported many of
these businesses to grow,
and some of these
businesses are our own.
You might know that we
have a search engine,
and we have a platform where
people can share and publish
videos, and we also help
people to exchange emails.
All of these businesses
have grown over the years,
and each business has more
than 1 billion customers today.
So our track record
is pretty good, right?
Our track record to
help businesses to grow
is pretty good.
And there's no magic.
It is all in the investment
we have made in our data
centers and our facilities.
So underneath it all, we
customize a lot of things.
We customize bus taps so we
can supply a lot of power
into our data center, we
customize cooling systems,
we even have machine learning
so then our data center
can run even more efficiently.
So for example, let's take
PUE, Power Usage Effectiveness.
It is the ratio of the
total amount of power
you put into a data center
divided by the amount of power
consumed by IT equipments.
So in a perfect
world, PUE is what?
One, right?
And now, if we take any data
center around the world,
the industry norm
to run a data center
is 1.5, which means every 1.5
power you put into the data
center, and only 1 watt
is used for IT equipments.
And at Google, because
of our investments,
we're so good at running
efficient data centers,
our PUE is 1.1.
In addition to the
data center investment,
we also want to make sure
that all data centers are
connected all around the world.
So we invest in
subsea optical cables.
And here's a picture of our
engineering team laying down
the cables.
There are total 13 of
them around the world,
And they're both underneath
the Atlantic, as well as
the Pacific Oceans.
And these cables are
so long that we even
need to put in
repeaters, so that we
can repump the optical
power, periodically.
And the investment
doesn't just stop there.
In the past three years, we
have invested $47 billion.
We serve more than 1 billion
IP addresses every day,
we have 5,000 caching points,
and our machine uptime
is four nines.
Here are some
additional statistics
about our infrastructure.
We have 19 regions,
and our track record
is-- we have been growing five
to six regions every year.
Feel free to take a photo.
Here's a visual,
which is putting all
of the statistics on this map.
And the point of all of this, as
I mentioned, time has changed.
Engineers no longer
need to worry
about where the
computers are, where
they're located,
what size they are,
and wait weeks in the queue.
All of these machines,
this entire infrastructure
you're seeing here on the
map, is available to you
from your laptop.
And the infrastructure
is offered to you
as services or products
from Google Cloud.
We have a wide category of
compute, networking, storage,
products, software,
or service, et cetera,
and we're continuously making
your products every day.
And so this week, in
the past couple of days,
you might have already heard
a lot of product-- new product
announcements.
Instead of going through
the entire catalog,
I picked out a few that I
thought this particular crowd
might be interested in.
So during the keynote, we talked
about two new machine types.
C2 and M2.
C2 is the compute-optimized
compute engine that
can go up to 3.8 gigahertz.
And the M2 is a
memory-optimized compute engine,
and they can go up
to 12 terabytes.
So imagine, you have some
scale up crazy simulations.
These two machines might
come in very, very handy.
And knowing that our product
catalog is pretty wide.
So our product manager Hanan
organized a session yesterday--
so this is the second QR code--
organized a session
yesterday to give you
a walk-through of our
entire GCE product catalog,
and also to show you how to
pair each one of our machines
to the specific use case
that you're interested in.
I picked a third
talk that is storage,
and the storage is special
because the storage focuses
on HPC systems.
So, again, you might
be interested as well.
And the last one I picked
is on cost savings.
You know that is
always a hot topic.
You may or may not have
missed these sessions.
If you have, that is
OK because they're
going to be available
online for you to look at.
So with all of these services
and tools available to you,
you already have everything you
need to run your HPC workloads.
And, if you're interested,
to not DIY, but also
choose a partner
product, we also
have a lot of partners
in the HPC ecosystem
that are currently
working with us.
So for example, we have
systems integrator partners,
we have storage partners, we
have HPC application partners.
And what we mean by HPC
application is, for example,
in CAE you have Altair right?
A famous CAEs vendor.
Or in EDA we'll have Synopsys.
And we also are working
with job scheduler partners
so that they can help us manage
the entire infrastructure
for our customers.
And today, we would like
to show you-- you know,
seeing is believing--
we would like to show you
couple of our partner solutions.
And let's jump into it.
Google Cloud has
made NVIDIA GPUs
available through our platform.
And, in the past,
I would not have
imagined to be able to
render anything on the cloud.
And the way we enable
GPU through our cloud
is to make sure that
we set up the GPUs
in the passthrough mode, and
so that the performance is
bare metal performance.
And also, because of the
flexibility of the cloud,
you can attach GPUs
to any instances,
and then you can mix-match
the configurations
of the infrastructure.
For example, a different
memory, different CPU,
and different NVIDIA
[? SKU ?] types.
And here are a list
of NVIDIA GPU types
we have available on GPU--
and on GCP, and
each one of them is
targeted for a very
specific type of use case.
For example, if
you're looking at more
memory-bound or compute-bound
kind of problems
and you might want to
pick a specific GPU
that satisfies your need.
And today, we actually
have T4 [? SKU ?] GA today.
And they're available globally,
in EMEA, America, as well as
APAC.
They're available in
the [INAUDIBLE] regions.
And so T4 is very good at
solving memory-bound problems.
And we'll have Edward
here, from NVIDIA,
demonstrating the power of T4.
EDWARD RICHARDS: Today--
welcome, by the way.
Today, we're going to show
some of the power of using
NVIDIA on Google Cloud.
The demo we have to show you
is a dwarf star explosion.
And so you might use
some large compute
to take this radio
telescope data to crunch it
in FP 64 using a
[INAUDIBLE] line
or a Pascal line of
supercompute GPUs.
And then in this
case here, we want
to visualize it to
get some insight.
And so because NVIDIA
has T4s in the cloud,
I can spin up instances.
And, in this
particular workload,
it's a memory-bound
problem to visualize it
in a way to get insight.
It's not a
compute-bound problem.
So the T4 is actually a
perfect balance for that job,
so I chose T4s.
But it's a very
large amount of data.
It's a couple of
terabytes that you
need to be processing
in real time
to be able to visualize it.
And so what we do is we use a
NVIDIA product called INDEX,
which is able to do
volumetric rendering
across many nodes in many GPUs.
So we actually have 144
jobs running at a cluster.
I make an instance
group, and then
I just deploy click
to deploy, and I
get 36 nodes of four T4s each
just pushed out into the cloud.
And then I have a web server
able to connect to it.
So, if we jump across to my
laptop, I can show you a demo.
And before I put
the mic down, I'll
just explain a little bit
about what you're seeing here.
So this is the data set we
have, and the colors are matched
to different frequencies that
are detected by the radio
telescope.
And there's sort of
two dimensions to that.
We have the top coloring,
which is how you want
to visualize the frequency.
And then the second
dimension of that
is, for the given
amount of energy
of that particular frequency
of that particular particle,
we can change the
color map as well.
I'll let Michelle speak
to you a little bit more
about some of the
astrophysics fun,
and I'll start playing with
it and showing you how you
can see different components.
It's more than just the
visualization, right?
This diagram is being
done using 144 blocks.
Think of it cubes.
But it's more than just
making it look pretty.
It's about finding insight.
And so I'm going to show you how
you can interactively do that
by changing the
parameters to see
different interesting features.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MICHELLE XU: So this is
a supernova explosion,
and you may or may not know
the actual physics behind it.
You know, when
the star is dying,
near the end of its life,
instead of just quietly
going away, they explode.
They could explode.
And that's what
you're looking at is
different type of elements
and particles throwing them--
being thrown away from the
center of the explosion.
And I believe, yeah, we're
highlighting certain part
of the elements that's been--
So from a physicist's
perspective,
they can select different
part of the spectrum
to reveal on this
live simulation.
And so then they can know how
different particles interact
with each other, the trajectory
of their ejection, angle's,
profile, and all sorts
of scientific insights
they can gain from
this life simulation.
So here's a fun fact.
Oh this great--
EDWARD RICHARDS: Someone who
knows what they're doing.
MICHELLE XU: Yeah,
this is the fully--
this is the prerecorded fully--
fully compiled 360
view of a supernova.
EDWARD RICHARDS:
It's the same demo,
it's just that it's with someone
who knows what they're doing.
So they're able to
find the insights,
and have spectacularly found
those components to show us.
MICHELLE XU: And so
a little fun fact,
as you're watching
this play live.
So there is a star
called a Betelgeuse.
It's only 600
light-years away from us.
And Betelgeuse is so big
that when they experience
a supernova, which scientists
do believe it is going to go--
it's going to explode soonish--
and if, and when that
happens in our lifetime,
when everybody else is
looking at this a bright blob
in the sky, and all of us,
here, where we can say,
meh, been there, done that.
We've seen that at Google
Cloud Next in 2019.
EDWARD RICHARDS:
Thanks very much.
MICHELLE XU: That was amazing.
Everyone, give around of
applause for Edward and NVIDIA.
[APPLAUSE]
It was beautiful.
[END PLAYBACK]
EDWARD RICHARDS: Can we
get back to the slides?
MICHELLE XU: Cool.
That was one of
many amazing things
we can do with GPU in the cloud.
We have more than 600
GPU accelerated apps in--
available on our marketplace.
And each one of--
and all of these
apps are categorized
into different verticals.
And at Google Cloud, we have
different vertical teams
that are very specialized
and knowledgeable about how
the workload in each one
of these categories work.
And so I'd love to hear from
you after the talk, connect.
And I would love to introduce
you to our area and domain
experts so they can help you
to identify how to best run
your workload on Google Cloud.
And out of these 600 GPU
accelerated HPC apps,
more than 50 of them
are in containers.
We all like containers, because
you build ones run everywhere.
Easy to deploy,
easier to manage.
Here's our second demo from
a couple of our partners,
actually.
Do we all know what
preemptible VMs are?
Can I see a show of hands?
Preemptible VMs?
Nice.
Good, nice.
For those who don't know what
preemptible VM is, the name
itself is quite
self-explanatory.
There is a trade-off, right?
You can spawn a VM and there's--
with a preemptible VMs,
there a trade-off.
You can take risk of
jobs being preempted,
and at the same time, you
can enjoy the cost saving
of these preemptible VMs.
And I can see you some people
are already shaking their heads
because engineers do not
want to launch thousands
of batch jobs and wake
up in the morning knowing
that jobs are not done.
When we set up the--
our entire infrastructure with
a good scheduler and a good file
system in the back end, even
when the VMs are preempted,
the job scheduler can
recognize the preem--
the jobs are being
preempted, and save
the current state of the
job in the file system
in the back end.
And then put the job
back in the queue
and respawn it somewhere else,
and remount the file system.
And let's welcome David
from Elastifile and Brian
from SchedMD to show us
how to seamlessly manage
your preempted jobs
on Google Cloud.
DAVE PAYNE: Thanks, Michelle.
So we are going to
show you today--
To put it in context,
this last year Christmas
happened in December,
like it does every year.
And I had something
interesting happen.
I've been married for 20 years.
And so my 20th
Christmas with my bride,
and I got a gift
that I never expected
to receive on Christmas.
Usually, it's a sweater or
socks or something like that.
And this year I
opened this package,
and I got a Rustler 4 by
4 VXL Brushless Traxxas
remote control car.
Amazing, right?
I did not expect this.
Thank you.
And that's a reward for 20
years of marriage, I guess.
But it was really fun.
Something-- a toy.
I have children, but
something I could play with
and it would be amazing.
So I live in the Great
White North of Minnesota,
where it's snowy all the time.
So I took this out over the last
few months and put it to work.
And I want to show you what
it looks like when it runs.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [INAUDIBLE]
(CAR WHIRRING)
- Oh, man.
What a landing.
- Whoa.
[END PLAYBACK]
DAVE PAYNE: All right.
Tons of fun.
We had a great time
playing with these toys.
So later that weekend,
my 17-year-old son
said, let me play with it.
So right behind
what you just saw
is a hockey rink, which
is pure ice, if you don't
live in a place that's cold.
So he goes out, the
sun's coming down,
and he's ripping
away with the car.
And he gets kind of into the
distance, and all of a sudden I
hear a thud.
And it stops.
Right?
No good.
Everything was broken.
He ran straight into a
fire hydrant at probably 40
miles an hour, all right?
So I take the car home,
and I want to fix it.
And I'm pretty good
at fixing cars.
I've been doing
this my whole life,
I have a whole
garage full of tools.
And nothing works.
Everything's miniature.
I have no replacement
parts, I have
no tools that fit these little
tiny screws and everything.
So I'm out of commission
for several weeks.
And I had to go get
schematics, and figure out
how to rebuild these systems.
I had to go order tools
and replacement parts
and all of that.
And so, essentially,
three or four weeks later,
I had built an entire tool
bench to manage this gift
that I got for Christmas.
But I got it back up and
running, better than ever,
and it's amazing and
doing great today.
So I share this story
with you because I
think it's consistent
with the experience I've
heard from a lot
of our customers
we've been working
with, as they've
tried to take high performance
applications from how they're
running on-prem today
and into the cloud.
And we get really excited
about the engine, the tools,
the preemptible
VMs, and containers,
and automatic scheduling,
all this great stuff
that can happen in the cloud.
And often, we get there
and we get started,
and then we figure out,
my tools in my garage
aren't quite compatible with
what's out there in the cloud.
So we came together,
and this is really
what we've been
working on jointly
with Google Cloud,
with the SchedMD folks,
with Slurm, and Elastifile.
We're really here to take a
lot of that complexity out
of the equation,
and try to shorten
the gap between
what you do today
and what you might do in Cloud.
And so we want to show
you how this works.
We put together a demo that's
sort of simply architected
like this.
It's running in a Google
project completely.
Slurm will be stood
up, we're going
to deploy a whole bunch of VMs.
Preemptible VMs, actually.
We'll use Elastifile for
the back end storage,
and we actually have an
application that we authored
called E-run, which does a
pretty intense type of storage
load generation.
And we're going to show
you what happens as we go.
OK, so I want to have Brian
come up, and he's going to--
actually, not yet.
So let me break
down the components,
real quickly for you,
that are going to happen.
So on the Elastifile side,
if you don't know us,
what we are is,
essentially, a scale-out
file system that's designed
to operate, essentially,
natively inside of
Google Cloud, OK?
It presents as an NFS server.
Really simple.
No client-side software
needed, standard
NFS you've been using
for 10, 20, 30 years.
But on the back end, it's a
highly distributed file system
that handles embarrassingly
parallel connections really
well.
It runs completely
inside of Google Cloud.
So any region, any zone.
It can stand up and run in
a mere matter of minutes.
The system, like I
said, it's NSF v3.
It's designed to handle--
it's scale-out, so as
you need more capacity,
you scale horizontally.
You need more performance,
And then when you're done with
that performance capacity,
you can shrink it back
in, which actually works.
It's elastics in and out.
So it's designed to get to large
capacities integrated for--
with Google Cloud Storage.
So it can tier.
As you-- as your
data gets cooler,
and you don't want to move
it into a different place,
you can just cool it off.
It'll push the inactive
files into Cloud Storage,
but keep the entire
namespace populated,
so the applications
still see all their data.
It's a highly available system,
if that's important to you.
You can either run
it in a single zone,
or many zones in a region,
or all the zones in a region,
and even do asynchronous
replication across zones.
Upgrades are automatic
and non-disruptive.
And then tiering, as I said,
we can tier active data
into Cloud Storage.
You can also take
snapshots of data
and store them directly into
Google Cloud Storage, which
is a great thing if you
use storage on premises.
The traditional
filers, often, you
have to reserve a big chunk
of your data for redundancy,
and another big chunk of
your capacity for snapshots.
In this case, we can keep all
of the performance capacity,
which, in our case, runs
completely in Google Cloud
Engine, and then any
data for snapshots
can be stored in a
GCS at a lower cost,
and keep all of your primary
tier available for performance.
Lastly, there is a
capability called
Cloud Connect, which is a
data shipper for moving data
in and out of Cloud.
This helps solve
some of the gap.
When I have a large
data set on-prem,
and I'm trying to figure out
how to get it in the cloud,
we can move all of that.
And we keep all the POSIX stuff
as POSIX, mtime, atime, ctime,
ACLs, any of the metadata.
And so, even to
the point where we
can capture hard
links and soft links,
essentially take a
full snapshot of a data
set, drop it in Google,
and start operating, OK?
So you have two options.
You can deploy this in your
projects, you manage it,
we support it.
Or fully managed service,
which is effectively
gone to a self-service
mode over the last week.
Both of these accessible
through Google Marketplace.
The QR codes will get you there.
Click the link,
hit Go, and you're
up and running
within a few minutes.
As a matter of
fact, Brian, who's
going to come up now
and talk about Slurm, he
actually, during the
demo, used the service
to do to do the implementation.
So let me hand off to Brian.
BRIAN CHRISTIANSEN: OK.
Thanks, Dave.
So I'm Brian Christiansen.
I'm with SchedMD.
We are the maintainers of the
open source workload manager
slash job scheduler.
So a little bit about Slurm.
Traditionally, we
find Slurm in the--
more on the on-premise side.
So, for example, in Slurm's on
five of the top 10 biggest HPC
systems in the world.
And then also, when we're
going up into the top 100,
we're on 40% the top 100.
So Slurm's scheduling a
wide range of use cases,
going from capability
to capacity machines,
and also scheduling a
hybrid of those workloads.
For example, we've
got a customer
that does 14,000 jobs a minute
in high throughput environment.
So it's a little bit
about Slurm in the cloud
and where does it fit.
So a couple options of having--
of Slurm in the
cloud is one, you
could have Slurm as a
standalone clustered all in GCP.
So you have your controller,
your login nodes,
and all your compute
nodes, and then
what Slurm has
auto-scaling capability,
so it'll automatically create
and delete VM instances and GCP
according to the workload.
And then also--
So if you've got an
on-premise system,
you could just
burst out into GCP,
just actually
compute nodes there,
and using the auto-scaling
capabilities there.
And then a hybrid
solution of the two
is having your on-premise
cluster and a cluster
in the cloud, and beyond
those scheduled jobs,
submit jobs between the two.
And so we've worked with--
we've been working
with Google to make
it easy to set up a Slurm
cluster in the cloud easier,
and that's this repo,
the Slurm GCP repo.
So we're going to jump into the
demo that Dave and I created.
So as Dave explained, the demo--
in the demo, we're
going to set up
an Elastifile cluster,
a Slurm cluster,
and submit a whole bunch
of jobs and watch them run.
So we'll show how
easy it is to do.
OK, so this is the
Elastifile as a service.
We're going to go
ahead and create that
from the marketplace.
We're just going to give it--
go ahead and give it a name,
choose our region and the zone.
We're going to
head into the East.
And then there's some profiles
that just kind of give you
some base options.
How much capacity.
And then we're going
to choose the network
that it's going to
reside in, so we're
going to do the default one.
So we're going to head--
so that's going to
go ahead and create.
We're going to spin it up.
And the important thing that
we're looking for right now
is this share name.
This is the mount
point that we're
going to mount inside
of our instances.
So Elastifile's done.
We're going to go ahead and
create our Slurm cluster.
We're going to go to the
repo that we just saw,
clone it, and then set up
the configuration file.
And inside the
configuration file--
so I'm going to set it up so
that we've got 1,000 nodes
that we can burst out into.
And since the Elastifile
cluster's in the East,
we're going to go ahead
and put the cluster there.
And our network was
the default one.
If you don't do the default,
the Deployment Manager
will actually create
its own network for it.
And we're going to do eight
just to get a bigger bandwidth.
And preemptible bursting, that's
so that any node that gets
bursted out to is going
to be a preemptible VM.
And then this is just
for a Slurm accounting
so that will run my jobs using
my email address when I SSH in.
OK, so we're going
to do a little bit--
just a little bit more setup.
So taking that mount
point, we're going to--
this is a script that's
going to mount the Elastifile
service inside the instances and
install some things for them.
The erun that Dave
talked about, this
is the load generator
created by Elastifile.
And then we're going to
go ahead and copy that
into the deployment
scripts, and so when
we create the deployment
they'll get pushed up.
OK, so we use Deployment
Manager to create the instances.
You're going to see
in Deployment Manager,
we created a router, an
instance for the controller,
an instance for the login
node, and you'll also
see a instance that is a G--
that is the compute image.
So what the compute
image is, is that it's
going to be a
dummy compute node,
and once it gets
installed, then we're
going to make a snapshot of
itself, create an image of it.
And then anytime
we burst out, we're
going to use that image
so that we can burst--
we can start up
VMs a lot quicker.
So I'm just logging
into the controller.
We'll see how the make installs.
On-- down here on the bottom
right, I'm SCP'ing up,
just the script to do the erun.
And my tmux.conf.
OK, once that's-- once
that's finished installing,
I'm just going out to the login
node where we're going to run
the job from, and just set up
some monitoring on the side.
But on the-- so
here, on the right,
I'm going to go into
the images page,
and you'll see that the
compute image is creating.
Once that is completed--
So while it's building--
until it's done completing,
Slurm has marked
the controller--
the queue or the partition
is in a downstate
so no jobs can run on it.
But we see that nodes are up--
We see that Slurm's
available to run jobs,
but it's not in a state to
run run them yet until those
compute image finishes.
Once it finishes, it calls
home and marks the queue
in the partition in an
upstate so it can run jobs.
And once it's up, the compute
image will delete itself
and will go away.
So here, we see that
the Elastifile mount has
been mounted inside, at
least the login instance,
and it's been mounted
across everywhere.
So right here, I'm
submitting a job that's
going to run on 10 nodes.
And it's just going run
hostname on 10 different nodes.
And it takes about 40--
49 seconds to finish there.
And so this will scale out
about every 1,000 nodes,
we have to back off a
little bit because we're
hitting API limits,
but we can spin up
about 5,000 nodes in 7 minutes.
Here, I'm going to go ahead
and submit the erun script.
And this is an array job
and it's going to be a--
it's-- basically,
it's 1,000 jobs.
We're going to spin
up jobs and each job
is going to be on
its own compute node.
So we'll see all the nodes
have been fanned out,
they're starting up.
We see all the compute
nodes being created.
And on the left, we're
just waiting for them
to check in with Slurm.
And once they check in--
and while they're checking in,
Slurm is starting the jobs.
So you can see over here,
on the Elastifile graphs,
that they're starting
to filter in--
starting to run.
And then we speed up.
And what you're going to see
next is a couple of these VMs
are going to get preempted.
Slurm is going to detect that
the VMs have been preempted,
jobs are going to get requeued.
Jobs that were on those
nodes got requeued,
and so they become eligible
to run after two minutes.
And then Slurm will either--
Slurm-- We go ahead and
restart the instances
when they've been preempted.
And then these jobs are
eligible to either run
on the node that--
it could run on that
note that was preempted
or it could fan
out-- or it could
spawn more nodes to run on.
So right here--
So right now,
we've run our jobs.
There-- they were
10-minute jobs.
And now we're going
into the tail of it.
And this is just finishing
off the preemptibles--
the preemptible jobs.
And then what we're
also going to see,
too, is all these
compute nodes are
going to clean them self off.
After they've been idle for
a default of five minutes,
Slurm will start
tearing them down.
So we spun up 1,000
nodes and they all
checked in within
about three minutes,
and they completed the--
and then the
preemptibles tailed off.
So pretty simple to set up an
Elastifile cluster and a Slurm
cluster in GCP.
DAVE PAYNE: Right on.
And actually, Brian did all that
work pretty much by himself.
When we start recording the
demo, he went and grabbed--
I showed him how
to find Elastifile,
and then he came back and said,
OK, I already built all of it,
it all works.
So a testament of an end
user to a large extent.
So essentially what we
just saw, to recap that,
is, as Brian said,
three minutes,
we had 1,000 jobs queued and
another 1,000 machines created.
And as you saw as
they showed up,
work was starting to fly through
the system, so super fast.
And even at that job, we
sped it up a little bit,
for time's sake.
No one wants to
watch a cake cooking.
But in that short
amount of time,
I think it was up for 15
minutes, maybe, total,
from start to finish, about
1% of the 1,000 machines
were preempted.
And a preemptible machine
lasts for max 24 hours, right?
Whether it's a
GPU- or CPU-based.
But even still, in that short
amount of time, they were lost.
And so we did a session with--
an HPC session last year
with Silicon Therapeutics,
using GPUs that
were preemptible.
And they didn't
have this feature.
You guys hadn't released your
feature, yet, with Slurm.
And so every day, he had to go
in and requeue all these jobs.
It was a manual process to
find what broke and fix it all,
so that's a really great thing.
And then most importantly,
if you've ever
been caught in the
cloud issue, which
is a month later I forgot to
turn off all these machines,
Slurm prevents all of that.
It left no trace.
As soon as the jobs are
idle, it cleaned them up
and the billing stops
immediately, which is great.
Your accountants will like that.
So 1,000 machines spun
up, parallel NFS running,
very simple configuration.
He didn't have to install
any storage stuff.
It just works out of the box.
We were sustaining
2 and 1/2 gigabytes
of sustained throughput
through the system,
and all of the data that
was written in those jobs
was persisted even though,
when a preemptible goes down,
the data gets deleted.
So that's the net of that.
We took preemptible
machines, which
by nature are non-persistent and
unpredictable in when they're
going to go up and down, and we
eliminated the unpredictability
of the non-persistence of data.
We added Slurm and added
this extra predictability in,
sort of, accounting cleanup so
we could deliver reliability,
predictability for HPC.
Lastly, the question is, hey,
great, but what's the cost?
And so we ran the
numbers to make sure
that this is
actually achievable,
and essentially the cost
impact is negligible.
If you look at the total cost
of running large HPC systems,
most of it is compute oriented.
So if you compare a standard
compute-based system
to preemptibles, typically
are about-- they're about 80%
less expensive.
You add in Slurm and Elastifile,
we did a model over a week
and it was just a few percent
difference in the total price.
So your savings are
still 75% to 79%
over what a standard
deployment would look like.
Michelle?
MICHELLE XU: Yeah, thank you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVE PAYNE: You're welcome.
MICHELLE XU: Thank you, guys.
Now we know how--
all know how to utilize the
cost savings of-- the beauty
of preemptible machines, as
well as getting our job done
in a timely fashion.
And if you'd like to learn
more about Elastifile,
take a photo of this.
We'll have a session tomorrow.
All right.
Oh, sorry.
There you go.
Let me wrap this session
with a user story.
This user is extremely
special to us,
because it is our own
engineering design
team, our own
semiconductor chip team.
And that's why we call the
story a Google on Google story.
Although this is a Google
semiconductor chip engineering
team, but our engineer
team resonates.
They have the same
problems, their design based
on same principles,
they use the same tools
as everybody else in the world.
So in case you're not familiar
with semiconductor chip design,
you lay out a hardware
design, and then
you put in some boundary
conditions, input conditions,
and you similarly
the design first.
When you're happy with the
final simulation results,
you send that blueprint
to a manufacturer
to be manufactured.
And then the manufacturers
send the sample chips back,
and you measure them and
to see if the results are
exactly how you design
it and the results
are what you're expecting.
If not, likely you have to go
back and retweak the design,
and send it back to the
factory, now probably beta,
and then the factory sends
the sample chip back,
you measure it again.
So this whole iteration
takes one year, two years,
easily several years.
Easily.
So our own chip design
team is thinking,
there has to be a way where
we can reduce the engineering
design cycle.
And so they decided
to move to the cloud.
And just like everybody else
in the world, they're thinking,
we don't want to
refactor our workflow,
we do not want to redo our
system, and, at the same time,
we want all of the
benefits from the cloud.
So in the early stage of
their workload migration,
they've decided that, OK, we'll
keep our interactive sessions
on prem, and we'll keep majority
of our repositories on prem.
And now when it
comes to batch jobs,
we need to launch
thousands of them,
and we don't even have
this amount of machine
on premises, so we'll
do that in the cloud.
And if you're familiar with
semiconductor chip design,
or if you have paid
attention to some
of the jobs you have
ran in the past,
you will notice that some
jobs require more CPUs,
some require more frequency,
some require more memory.
And so our own design
team, when they
looked at the
profile of our jobs,
they decided to
use custom machine
types, which is a product
that's available in Google Cloud
today.
So custom machine
types really is
a cost saving play so
you don't overprovision.
And then they are
using containers,
because it's easier to
deploy, easy to manage.
And our own team is also, as
we just saw in the demo earlier
by Elastifile, as
well as Slurm, we
saw that, if we're
able to manage
preemptible VMs properly,
we can actually have
quite a bit of cost saving.
And also be very efficient with
our engineering design cycle.
And lastly, and probably
the most importantly,
is security and compliance.
Those hardware layouts
are extremely sensitive,
and our team has
the same concerns
as everybody else in the world.
So I'll flash this very
high-level architectural design
that our own team's deployment
has today in Google Cloud.
On the left is their
on-premises deployment.
It's standard compute, plus
some storage components
and it's connected to
Google Cloud through a VPN.
And in their cloud,
they will have--
they stage their jobs--
when it comes to
job staging, you
have your design files,
inputs, parameters, boundary
conditions, all loaded
in cloud storage.
And then they will have
different persistent disks
to load different design tools.
And then, eventually,
all the computation
is done in either custom
machine types, containers,
or just normal VMs that are
available on Google Cloud
today.
And so this work was
actually done before the C2
and M2s were announced or made
available to our customers.
So the C2 are the
high frequency ones,
the M2 is a 12 terabyte
machine, so I highly
suspect our own team might go
in and try our own C2 and M2
machines very soon.
So that is all the content
we have today for everyone
and thank you for joining us.
And so to recap, we are
no longer limited by what
computers we have in our labs.
We're no longer limited by
where the computers are.
Time has changed.
We're in the era where
engineers are empowered.
We're more efficient
at what we do,
and so we can clear
room in our schedules
so we can solve more
problems and make
bigger impacts in the world.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
We have a HPC link here if you
want to check out the content
and assets we have today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]